welcome everybody
I've gathered you all here today
before chainsaw demo chainsaw demo
rather which was just released today
after capcom's Spotlight and I am super
excited to play it so for context I've
said this before there is footage of me
on the internet playing Resident Evil 4
it is a game that I have played before
but I've never finished it um I would
say I've played the first half three
quarters of this game a whole bunch of
times but I've never finished it and as
I was getting close to doing so on
Oculus which I still think sorry Rift
meta oh my God
uh which I still think I'll go back and
do I was like the remix just been
announced
I'm super excited to play it this way
what's up
let's do it thankfully you can play this
one as many times as you like and
there's no time limit so I will take it
slow because I feel like the other ones
really stressed me out because I felt
like I had to rush
[Music]
I already did the settings before uh
before the Stream So December 30th 1998.
tell me how the audio is as well the day
I'll never forget
the cop inside me died that day
that night Raccoon City was wiped out
thanks to the bioweapons created by
Umbrella
somehow I made it out but too many
others
weren't so lucky it's pretty messed up
[Music]
I was asked later to join a top secret
government program
not that I had a choice
related everyone
the podcast that I do with voice actors
every month or every few months this
month kept my mind off is with Nick who
voices Leon I could just forget
[Music]
dude
textures look at him go
it's been six years since Leon S Kennedy
survived the Raccoon City incident an
unprecedented biological catastrophe
caused by the Umbrella Corporation
having distinguished himself as a U.S
Special Agent he is tasked with locating
the president's missing daughter the
search has brought him to an isolated
Village in Europe where Intel suggested
the kidnapped girl was last sighted even
Leon's past trauma could not prepare him
for the nightmare the insanity he would
find there and now on Sky News
um
oh my God I'm so excited and also very
scared already
dude it's it's so dark out here oh no oh
no
and now to Jill Valentine with the
weather
again I don't know why a million people
haven't cost me as uh news reporter's
it's right there
I'm also just uh talking to make myself
feel less nervous quickly
well that's a dang Bob while we're there
what we gonna do about that
this looks amazing dude they've been
just just killing it out here with the
Resident Evils I tell you they just been
killing it
I don't feel the need to run but thank
you
irregular controls appreciate that
how far could he have gone
[Applause]
hey bud are you okay you're just napping
right
surely that's just a nap
you'll be fine
I'm playing on Xbox hip cats
Crouch
[Applause]
oh boy
I know what happens in here
though isn't the bridge sort of like I
guess we must have just crossed the
bridge Maybe what does that happen I
think that happens before this
so many flies in these later Resident
Evil games too there's just so many
flies
everybody's goddamn stinky
oh we're not at the bridge yet this is
before the bridge is hit okay
noted
oh yeah that means yeah the dog with the
the dog situation
is uh
also after that
anyone home
so much detail
isn't there somebody around here
oh no I wish that like the fact that my
memory of this game is fractured feels
like it's making it worse
like it's
like I'm trying to piece things together
and it's making it more daunting oh
that's cool Hello I do buddy hello well
somebody clearly lit the fireplace
nice sick yes what does it say crew jump
judgment is an eye
you hate to see it
all right
squeaky squeaks
I think this one's locked
I don't know I wish
I gotta catch me
it doesn't work that way oh man
shut up guys you're talking too much
sorry to barge in like this
manzanas
IA
oh
Leon is very strong
I repeat Leon
very strong
all right sick thanks for that that's
all I needed
uh a cab
take a net uh sorry Mario
she's also just taking a nap I think
dude I'm so impressed by the environment
detail after having played this again
semi recently
so good
oh boy too good some might say that's
what people are saying
man that stinks I bet this game is
really high up on stinky games
like
it's this and bloodborne
two of the smelliest games ever made uh
where did the door go
okay it's back this way I was like
wasn't there a door there oh the horror
horror
American Dad's face is smelly I think
Dead Space probably smells like um
like a hospital like some of the Rotting
Flesh might do it but
I don't think that overall Dead Space
would smell that bad because like this
is like
well no I guess the woods kind of
usually smell nice it's all the like
stanky rotten corpses that do it
dog
so impressed
this is so atmospheric from The Jump Man
I'm just so happy with all these remakes
and the recent Resident Evil games as
well like I just think after a couple of
questionable middling maybe games
um I love all of them recently
are you okay
hello
radio is making me think of PT and it's
making me really nervous
thank you frankly Jim thanks
I reach you
what's your situation
seems bad seems like it might be bad
seems like the situation might be bad
just the vibe I'm getting
okay
why are you telling me I need that why
do I need that why do I need to know how
to shoot I don't want to know how to
shoot why would I ever need to do any of
that that doesn't make sense
there's got to be more in here hang on
map
current position and objectives on the
map if you have a treasure map you'll
also be able to see the locations of
hidden valuables
um is it giving me the colors though
like for if things are completed or not
I suspect that this is all completed is
what it's telling me
but a hot dang who knows
am I okay okay
foreign
I love that he's got the proper
combat stance that's cool
no [__] way
[__] [__] oh it's so fast how is he so
fast oh I didn't expect you to move that
quickly
oh God oh God oh God oh God
be that quick I thought he would be like
a like a regular zombie so please sir
oh no
okay okay that seems fine I'm sorry
about that Jesus
where did you come from is that the guy
from upstairs
hello
okay
oh don't I get jumped here and God no
that's the other house hang on one where
I go out the window
oh God it's not a stealth game Milana
you start oh [__]
oh no okay
with any more Collectibles for me no all
right
all right thank you last night
oh geez
I think I'm supposed to come up here
first but
Bruce
here what's your sit rep
our Intel is correct then well done
need a location on a nearby lake she may
have been taken there copy that I'll see
what I can find
something's happened to the people here
my escorts are
The Vibes off yeah talk later
oh no oh God
that's right okay the window great ah
yeah
don't worry about it let's keep moving
don't worry don't worry but it seems
fine that was normal just totally it was
a
hallucination
that was a sick jump come on now his
jump was awesome also thank you too
hit me Vince and lost pants on Falls
appreciate you
just don't like visitors to be fair I
was trespassing that's on me
sick kick hell yeah
all right I should probably just stop
thinking there are Collectibles
everywhere right like this is just a
demo
to release a circle
yes dude
oh
devastating okay
that's a shame
but for reference everybody I
prioritized um
oh no uh prioritize frame rate
no
that's genuinely upsetting
why would you save him
g'day lads
beautiful lighting
big fan of the truck
oh you see me have you
that I think that was right in the dick
and I apologize because it was actually
an accident
okay
somebody else heard that oh God
oh [__] okay
three shots is fine
oh my God I jumped so hard I gave myself
a cramp
nah I don't want to waste it
oh that's when they come back with a
bent neck huh
maybe I should I'm just not sure about
how like the jury the knife has
durability right you can see it I'm like
my webcam is just above the knife
durability uh but you can still see the
ball it's got a little bit out of it
um
try the knife perio I didn't even know I
could do that
um
so I'm not sure like how replaceable it
is or it's hard to say when I should use
it or not
I lost the whole demo
yeah that is uh how do I use melee
uh
just without LT got it okay
cool
ah son of a [__]
I was too busy throwing my knife around
you know I feel like you recovered from
that real fast mate hello
hello
just try it
maybe don't try it you know maybe not
definitely only try it when they're down
it's my
it's my thought with how that went
uh yes red hubs let's go wait I need
green hubs
oh no sorry I mean I need the the um
Med mad stuff which I currently do not
have the the
red herb can be combined with other
herbs
herbs all right I have first aid spray
let's just use that
nothing else
lash grenade
great shot
I I don't I don't want to use the flash
grenade right now
I guess you really want me to
dude for real neat Leon's conditioner
how good does his hair look look at the
shine on this man
we hit the town already
oh no
oh we are aren't we well well heck well
dang and heck day
hello
foreign
I love that Leon's just like looking at
somebody being murdered from afar as a
cop and is like
smells like barbecue
you're not gonna intervene
tasty
I have
herbs to collect don't you know
certain materials such as resources
gunpowder and knives can be used to
craft different items the types of items
you can craft can be increased by
obtaining new crafting recipes
you can set a weapon shortcut by
selecting a weapon into minute up to
eight weapons can be a side Outlets I
only have two
interesting this is very different
but I like it
oh my God we got a we got a we got a
sort something we gotta sort some things
out you know what I'm saying
uh move
I'm just gonna have a lot ammo down here
heals in like in the middle and then
extra resources up here for now
let me go down here I'd also recognize
that this isn't going to be necessary
probably in the demo but I'm very
specific about how I do this stuff okay
okay
this woman I think and the person on the
roof are there in the exact same spots
in the original
I'm pretty sure there's someone working
okay can I stab you from behind I can
that's awesome
isn't that someone otherwise I swear
somebody threw stuff at me for my laptop
great shot
it's so noisy dude
there's so much noise
dude the the audio is very good oh God
oh God oh God no I don't want to flash
grenade you no no no no no
oh [__] oh God they're all here already
oh [__] [__] oh God
no no
okay we know that they will just keep
coming are they gonna throw stuff at me
though maybe they won't
because that's that's when things really
get to be getting spicy you know what I
mean
best
oh oh god oh slow down everybody just
everybody just calm no no
no all right yep good good good good
good and just keep moving and then we're
gonna throw out a grenade at least get
way to just get a grenade all of you but
baby okay that surely took out a couple
of them
maybe the flash grenade now there's so
many more to go though
foreign
you're just standing there with your
hands over your heads but
as much as I'm shooting you people
Invincible Dear God
[Music]
oh my God
it just doesn't it
I don't need any of these right now
no you don't no you don't
oh [__] I'm out of ammo
[__] snacks
well I love this nice little line that
I've made of them isn't that fun for me
oh okay oh [__] I don't have any ammo oh
[__]
frog I'm so scared I hate it I would
like to go home I want to go back to the
US
[Laughter]
oh [__] Jesus Christ no
no oh
that's a chainsaw and I don't have Amber
what am I supposed to do
okay [__] hell
I should have tried to stealth more of
them and I really I really I [__] it
up man
[__]
[Music]
look no [__] I've got to go in a room to
get some [__] ammo
oh God
oh God never just hear a chainsaw behind
you and and panic oh [__] you can't be
serious no [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
what are we supposed to do how do I get
out he's right there oh God oh God oh
God I don't think there's any way out of
here it's blocked I love myself
oh God
life goes at you real fast man that's
all I'm saying
foreign
because I didn't use the typewriter
okay let's
um just not do that do you know what I
mean
just not that
this is much harder than it was in the
original much harder
um because I think that's also what I
was expecting was it to be like kind of
similar volume of enemies as the
original
um it is not that it is definitely both
more of them and they're not throwing
the hatchets to the extent that they
were in the original
um but I feel like it was also way more
forgiving
it's definitely a lot harder
whatever man
all right let's just try and do better
I didn't know how was I to know that
somebody built a [__] house that the
only thing that was in it was that
no
all right
wait but don't they like come infinitely
for a certain amount of time anyway even
if I stealth kill them isn't that the
whole
isn't that the whole thing that they
come for a certain amount of time
regardless
isn't it
I just have to survive
[Music]
I I know that there's a way to get on
the roof
I can do that there's gonna be a lot of
somewhere just like in there is an re7
wait my name is eight that did it
is that the house that I ran into
[__] you house
it's not this is a difference oh nice
one Leon
foreign
I love that for me
a thing I don't think you can hide
I don't think hiding works I think they
will seek you out regardless if I recall
correctly you just have to run
you think the village sequence in R8 was
hot in here I don't know yet I'm not far
enough through it
I think I died once in Village
and then I realized what was happening
and I was like oh it's Resident Evil
lady please come to me
I'm going to kill you
no you two got me two out in the open
love come on come off it come off it
they're gonna see I mean I have to
trigger them eventually don't I
son of a [__] [__]
I'm just out here stealing stuff
take an ammo we do want the ammo I don't
know
Village you just ran around and made
Loops while I picked up what I could in
the village in Village rather I
I think I grabbed the gun and then ran
under the roof
I don't remember that gameplay is on the
internet
you could go and find it
I'm also definitely gonna do a
playthrough of this one
for the YouTube that I think that I
might do it on um what's basically like
my stream Vlog Channel I'm now using
kind of as a full new play Channel we'll
put the first hour up on my main Channel
uh I don't know that I'm gonna be able
to go to the right without them seeing
me but let's give it a shot shall we oh
hang on I'm doing my inventory nonsense
Inventory management and Resident Evil
is one of my favorite things
this is
all right
I reckon we can at least pick her off
let's let's just go do that shall we and
then try and cross and if I caught and I
trigger them it's gonna happen
eventually anyway so
we'll just let it happen
hello lady
no you don't turn around
Capcom hasn't created an art Inventory
management Bible Game Dude I would play
that for sure even if it accomplishes
nothing I'd be like
make sure I put my guns in the right
place
oh I can't go up that I wonder if I have
to trigger it first before it let me go
up
get out of here chicken
all right let's see if I sneak over here
sneak over here this way
he doesn't just run through this door if
I get close to it does he
because that would really kill my whole
vibe
nice
nice nice nice nice
Resources with an S I love those
more herbs that's good
I'm gonna come now where we are probably
not right
and the original chainsaw man only
appeared if you enter any houses the
last time I played it I actually did not
get chainsaw man so I just assumed that
that was a change
um from
I guess I mean still is a change right
but I I didn't I thought that he was
supposed to be some light apart in the
game and they moved him earlier for the
purposes of the remake because he did
not show up last time I played this
somebody running off to you with a
chainsaw will never not be like top 10
oh [__]
here we go
all right at least he says here we go so
I know yeah here we go
they're gonna start coming from behind
this one aren't they yeah
they look really good like their faces
all look so like
individual
hey get out of here
get get out of it
oh it gave me an a to Millie that's
interesting
I don't want money I want ammo
okay that time I think we're at the time
though pretty sure
thank you
sick this is much better
this is a massive Improvement all right
so it's not doing oh it sounds like
somebody's coming from my side it's not
doing oh God
the thing in the other remakes where
like you have to wait for the reticle to
get a little bit smaller for your aim
too
um I'm gonna try and go for the roof and
I think that was a way to get up under a
roof from over this way somewhere
you shut your goddamn mouth
somewhere
I hate him so much man I can't
okay okay okay oh why can't I go up no
that was my whole strategy oh [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
oh I didn't get the grenade that's bad
there's no point killing him is that do
I need to kill him I don't know I need
to kill you
shovel [__]
[Laughter]
[__] off [__] a [__] everybody just
[__] leave me alone man I'm just I'm
just out here vibing I got the chicken
egg thank you for the Raider went
without Wallace
how do you all even fit in this one
Village surely there's not enough space
for all of you
I like the music
okay he's there I see him
and I'm Adam
[__] dicks
leave me alone leave me alone what you
push me [__] I'll push you
that was a little funny
oh God oh God oh God oh God oh God
do we have any grenades what's the
grenaded yeah baby [__]
oh
why does he always feel like he's behind
me even when he's not behind me
do I have to kill more of them in this
version of the game or do I just have to
run
one of life's greatest Mysteries
oh my God the belt oh my God the belt
it wasn't that bad it wasn't that bad
oh it was fine it was fine I just played
really badly to begin with
oh God
foreign
don't ask how many I said don't judge me
I'm Australian we swear
dude that was very tense
[Music]
good day
of course everyone going
Bingo nice he said the thing
hell yeah
that's the end of the demo ah
I hoped it would be longer
that said
they
nailed the vibe it's so creepy
really really really creepy
um super atmospheric incredible audio
design
and I like some of the changes too like
the the changes to
again I'm not sure if it's different to
ogre4
but uh the changes versus the the other
remakes in terms like Inventory
management and crafting I think are cool
oh
my heart rate
so high
Dear God